una ola de sequía mundial los países más
vulnerables enfrentan las peores
consecuencias el cuerno de áfrica ha
tenido cuatro temporadas de lluvia
fallidas situación que ha desencadenado
una crisis alimentaria en la región
afectando a casi 17 millones de personas
por favor inviertan en estas comunidades
los gobiernos deben ver más allá de
ucrania hacia la difícil situación del
cuerno de áfrica ayúdenos a ayudar a las
comunidades a desarrollar una
resiliencia ante la terrible terrible
situación en francia 15 departamentos
del país tienen restricciones como regar
jardines y prohibición total de lavar
automóviles los meteorólogos la han
catalogado de sequía repentina y
temprana en los campos los agricultores
se debaten cómo utilizar mejor el agua
que tienen en reserva lo que si riego
bien el trigo me temo que no tendré
suficiente agua para regar el maíz hasta
finales de agosto
en eeuu los incendios forestales están
afectando ciudades como california y
nuevo méxico en este último llevan
ardiendo más de un mes obligando a miles
de personas a abandonar sus hogares y
devastando aproximadamente 824
kilómetros cuadrados de bosques sabemos
que las temperaturas van a estar por
encima del promedio pero nunca sabes lo
que la naturaleza te va a deparar cuando
te enfrentas a los efectos
multiplicadores del cambio climático
como lo son estas sequías según las
naciones unidas desde el 2000 el número
y la duración de las sequías ha
aumentado un 29 por ciento en los
últimos 50 años se ha cobrado más de 650
mil vidas humanas de 1998 a 2017 ha
dejado pérdidas económicas mundiales de
más de 124 mil millones de dólares y tan
solo este año más de 2.300 millones de
personas tienen dificultades para
acceder al agua